foreign
[Music]
there's a letter for you
it's for you and Maya Maya is really
interested
dear Edgar and Maya we would like to
invite you on a trip to good my
prefecture what eggy Goodman prefecture
is a beautiful place with many hot
springs including Japan's famous kusatsu
Onsen delicious vegetables in beautiful
nature please bring your family
PewDiePie and merge yeah can we can I
come Maggie no I'm bringing my giant
okay well then I'll be my S plus one we
look forward to having you in good my
prefecture you're sincerely is
good my prefecture the mayor invited us
and we got Grandma Chan this is the
mascot for good luck eggy do you like
her oh my God
[Music]
thank you Edgar thank you so much for
bringing us along to Grandma we're on
our way it's about two hours since we're
bringing Edgar we're driving but if you
take the shinkansen it's only 50 minutes
we've officially been invited we were
actually in gunma for our anniversary
but we had limited time that time so now
we get to go we get to explore some more
I'm really excited and Edgar you will
show us around I guess
oh
[Music]
we stopped at the same place as the last
time to charge the Tesla we got about an
hour to go I think quick uh pit stop
right again
see
look at me bow
wow
all right fine
what in the world is this
we made it
[Music]
I think this is they gave us Wasabi and
you grade it yourself
yeah it's coming usually when you get
wasabi it's not real Wasabi it's like
horseradish because it has to be freshly
made otherwise I think
it's awesome it's a good time
foreign
[Music]
which is one of the hot springs here we
saw it in a TV show years ago and we're
like damn that looks so cool and we
wanted to go last time we went to
Grandma right now we're checking it out
it should be cool
somebody's eager
this is so pretty hey the sun came out
foreign
have you seen the water you can feel the
heat even from here I think you can dip
your feet over there
oh it's so hot
that's nice
what is that put your tongue back in
[Music]
Yaki Dango I think it was called These
are famous in gamma
it's like Savory and sweet you want some
idea
[Music]
[Music]
you're going for a fortune
okay
maybe open a book is that what he said
you got a good life oh great Good
Fortune but it was your second game
[Music]
I'm not getting that technique
uh back feet
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
they hooked us up man damn
we get one each so I get that one hey
you're in the one in the middle
this is fancy
so I think we have a cold
yeah
whoa
damn this is so cozy you can hear the
rain
um they wrote my full name all right
very well welcome to Osama kazambo is
this for us
that's cool
all right cool
that's awesome so gunma sponsored this
trip so you have to go to Goodman right
now book your tickets to Goodman go to
Goodman let's do a tour of this place
this is amazing
welcome to my tour
can watch videos feet videos welcome to
my kitchen this is for our breakfast
tomorrow this right here this is the
tatami room
I sit here
oh yes I will studying my actually yeah
I'll study my company here
absorb
I'll talk to him you bites all right
Iggy sorry we put you in prison
oh he loves milk wow
this projector okay amazing
these were kids or 32 year old Swedish
man thanks very much saying I go to
sleep
and this is where I will sleep here's my
hair's actually we're honestly
this is amazing look at this
yeah
Damien 42 degrees they got a sauna well
that's it for my two see you guys the
Burma is famous for their vegetables and
they hooked us up look at this
so the water here is really clean that's
why I didn't get these amazing
vegetables
we're living like royalty right here
they give me milk he loves it
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I gotta be honest they hyped up The Corn
so much I didn't think it would live up
to the expectation
it's so damn good it's the best corner
I've ever had
it says and I don't even like corn that
much remember when I do my bowl
um
this is so amazing it's supposed to be
very spicy very spicy all right
it was good you're spiking that for me
[Music]
the colon they have ice underneath it
and then hot stuff so they got us both
you got the hot Style
400 years of History
that's good and it's cold
which really works this is an amazing
food 10 out of 10 so far
[Music]
Google
so my eye isn't with us she's fine I
don't know we we thought it'd be better
to leave her with the dog sitter so she
can stay at home and she can be more
comfortable because she's an old dog and
she relies on her routine we just
thought it'd be less stressful for her
but it is kind of
yeah we miss her maybe
oh we missed you
what a hottie oh that's the hottie yeah
what a goofy laugh yeah yeah yeah yeah
foreign
I'm making a sword
[Music]
this looks unreal we've been driving
through these mountains to get down
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's easy
[Music]
[Music]
wow get it
we have a lot of beds
the view is insane
[Music]
amazing so we're gonna have dinner at
the party damn
we're eating good in gunma
so we got a grill going on they got some
soy so you need for Merch
this is konyaku famous for
I'm supposed to put it with the wood
does this make sense to you because I
can't make sense out of this
[Music]
they got us dessert and look they got
this for Edgar
make what they got for you
it's Ranger
dogs I was like Marcus is gonna love
that
who's nay nay good boy sick good boy
sick wow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
breakfast
this is gaunting you know we always go
camping with the van and everyone's like
that's glamping now this is clapping
we're doing some more activities today
and then we're going back to Maya
so we miss her yeah do you like it okay
do you like your outfit
what a day it's not even hot yet
we were like driving over there before
it was so cool
[Music]
so we have to fill in the main quests
and the sub Queen all right let's go
oh my God I hit it
[Music]
small
what do you see Aggie what's the puzzle
[Music]
we got our corn
[Music]
all right we're going to our last stop
it's a DaRuMa Temple which are these
wish dolls yeah they look cool
let's check it out
[Music]
so the way things work is that you draw
one of the eyes when you have a goal and
then once you completed the goal you
draw the other eye and then for some
reason you completely like smash it when
you're done too
like you burn it up
[Music]
there's no space
[Music]
that was cool you get to go inside and
you see a huge collection of them the
aroma was the first first patriarch of
Zen in China and it started off to help
out Farmers first award of evil with one
eye and then it became a thing to
cells so the farmers could sustain
themselves if it was bad and then it
sort of became
yeah a bigger tradition it's interesting
well there's so many I didn't see the
black ones
wow
it's so big
you guys live good in here huh
Peggy
foreign
[Music]
last charge and I just saw this little
guy
hello I'm a little scared of like small
frogs I always feel like they're toxic
it's probably not
we're back baby are you mad at us
oh you look a little tired
what's that
was good man it was great thank you for
asking as we say in Sweden both Deborah
him my best that was an amazing trip
thanks for coming along and thank you
goodma for inviting us please have us
again go visit gunman book it right now
amazing Place amazing food amazing
people that's it for the Vlog smash like
subscribe
bye bye